ça tourne au nom non nettoyés vous les
gars c'est pas possible je vous aide à
vous de jouer
mais saddam aujourd'hui nous sommes avec
sofian jouini boudou et dany boon je te
trouve à chaque fois ça fait six ans que
tu te trouves à chaque fois que tu
prononces à notre famille et nous sommes
aussi avec nokia pour la première phase
des chaînes youtube
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
leclerc s'élève streamer sur twitter on
ne présente plus on est passé récemment
faire des courses il y avait un magasin
de jouets vous connaissez ma part j'ai
trouver des jouets des jeux de société
isabelle saab et spyker était archi
corps parfait j'en ai cinq chaque jeu va
nous mettre en compétition
à chaque fois il y aura deux gagnants et
un grand perdant le grand perdant devra
se taper la people
mel gibson est en 2013 je sais 2013 les
gars passion aux jeunes numéro 1 tout
lui dire c'est que des trucs les gars
c'est archi qu il ya un jeu dedans qui
est jean trop bien par contre jean c'est
vraiment une bonne idée qu'ils ont
évoqué mais je découvre je suis
[Applaudissements]
et c'est parti
voici le premier jeu c'est le plus cheap
de tous écoutez moi bien je ne comprends
pas le but du jeu donc tout ce dur cool
tu peux répéter des peluches coincé ça
vous avez donc ça sur la tête ses
troupes c'est tout je les ai vu je me
suis dit ah donc mesure cool cool j'ai
pris celui qu'il fait sonner le plus
rapidement possible le but c'est que ça
sonne pas je ne sais pas pourquoi ça
sauf mais genre si tu es stressé soi
disant ça sonne pendant que locklear
recherche les plus le regarde tes amis
vont faire tout ce qu'ils peuvent pour
que tu perdes ton froid tout le temps
son frère coule ton ton sang-froid dans
son salaire du lent au l'instrument de
torture
ça c'est quoi du coup je ne cois faut
faire des toutous le dfe dit de faire
soit un animal son animal fait des
bruits de pets je crois que c'est 3d en
fait c'est si tes potes n'ont pas
d'idées pour faire donc du coup ils te
dis oui cochon je pense les gars c'est
après qu'ils ont une vidéo claquettes
mans entend des mois sur cette faute
dans cette vidéo résumé de tout ce qui
vient de se passer on a mis 15 minutes à
comprendre comment marche cet outil en
gros ce truc-là detec la fréquence
cardiaque pendant 30 secondes la
fréquence cardiaque ne doit pas
augmenter si elles augmentent troll
alarme se déclenche pas perdu mais ces
dames bonne chance à vous c'est parti au
bateau et sa fille claude bessy saprykin
la merde refroidir mais qui va gagner
khelil a filmé à gagner il va gagner
ganic ils disent qu'il a gagné haut la
fed au bar dollars en boîte
vas-y à moi mais le biais d'un capteur
se sent venir la torre là il est bien et
bien plaqué sur le front d'un demi litre
on a pas le droit de me toucher closed
doors
mais c'est très apaisant de faire ça je
comprends leur tour n'a peut-être pas de
retouches et monsieur non la droite
qu'est ce qu'un à droite vers il a gagné
c'est pas comme toi allez combien de
bach aussi ok il faut tous combien selon
lui je propose sa compagnie qu'il a été
bonne tout humain qui t'a pas vu ta
n'était pas de but il a été battu
puis-je avoir quelques suspicions sur ça
oui ou non pas du pourquoi c'est quand
tu lances ya une lumière gens regardent
[Musique]
ça se trouve l'école des trucs de nous
aux sénonais mob en course assure cette
méga puisqu'on peut le truc hein
[Musique]
alors petite spécificité parce qu'il
peut s'en sortir en gros nous on doit
taper là et astruc qui montrent si t'as
pas tapé assez fort ce truc ne montrent
pas assez et du coup il se prend pas la
tête et on n'a que un essai chacun
ça va bien dedans
non non non non bien dedans bourrine
boeing bruine wacem est trop peur ça
fait trop peur c'est la guillotine ma
voiture vient on fait un tel geste pour
voir david
heureusement que j'avais ma main je suis
un pro gamer on a juste raté null null
null bennour - gardois de sang-froid
monsieur null null
[Musique]
l'eia cela cela elle n'a aucun sens
laissez moi vous présenter notre
troisième jeu ça te rappelle un petit
jeu flash non accueil et oui le avec
avec ça qui cédera vous allez voir le
principe est extrêmement simple
oula sang-froid le sang froid les règles
sont extrêmement simples ici un
réservoir rempli de glaçons ici un
bouton des fois quand appuyé sur le
bouton le réservoir à glaçons s'ouvre et
tous les glaces on tombe dans ton
t-shirt leclerc a voulu qu'on le fasse
en mode extrême on vient de mettre nos
t-shirts dans notre grand ballon ça va
être absolument ignobles quand quelqu'un
de masse il doit faire tourner la
molette la houlette lui dit s'il doit
appuyer une fois deux fois trois fois
sur le bouton il ya même un bouton ou
juste parce le masque et toi tu dois
payer trop fou qui commence a dit je
commence à temps nathalie passemard os x
et leur hockey deux tapis deux fois
oh [ __ ] le deuxième je me sens très
mal incroyablement stressant ok je suis
prêt je stresse dauphin j'avais un os ça
c'est pas si désagréable mais pourquoi
ça tombe sur moi maintenant ok à toi on
fait un bo3 on le fait mais kz3
déclencha jure c'est la sensation et les
deux agréables 2 encore ouais puis
lentement trois ans je suis mort dommage
deux très bien très bientôt sur sa tombe
et surtout variations absence est sur
moi
même en le faisant ils le savent et il a
fait bombardier - alesi ben sasson c'est
nous qui allons être encore humiliée ça
qu'on va pas réussir à taper la lui
vague légal écoutez moi je m'apprête à
faire le move le plus humiliant de
l'histoire de la chaîne youtube du
chauffeur je vais prendre un petit un
petit tabouret sarkozy mode
allez hop c'est pas soutenable c'est une
blague c'est impossible tellement sa
rivale il explose les crapauds
les gars nouveau jeu ça s'appelle
qu'ovide peuvent ball peuvent bon c'est
notre troisième je regardais au [ __ ]
je kiffe tu relis tes gobelets et le but
est que la balle mais peut-être que tu
écris tu as tu fait que de souffler
coli d'un donc on va poser de manière
très simple c'est un mode battle royale
c'est à dire je le fais si je foire
bah c'est à toi si tu réussit à gagner
reste que nous deux je commence nomme ce
trophée si c'est le meilleur jeu c'est
incroyable c'est très impressionnant
[Musique]
à l'aise castration à l'aise sofiane
vas-y mon frère je t'explique tu vas pas
au bout
c'est nul par contre tu ton album tu es
un beau gosse non au dessus au dessus
arrête toi on est les uns contre les
autres ah oui c'est vrai c'est chiant
[Applaudissements]
mais comment tu as fait one shot mais
que c'est impossible je suis juste un
bon j'ai pas du tout réussi moi vas-y un
démarrage à partir de là c'est celui qui
va le plus loin qui gagne vous avez un
essai chacun
let's go il faut trancher s'il passe pas
[Musique]
[ __ ] tu es foutu je vous tue sa mère
jusque là où hier sophie en écoute mon
frère mais triste on souffre qui s'ouvre
grand souffle continu à toi de jouer
moi j'ai pas eu ce traitement de faveur
d'un nul
c'est terminé c'est terminé liu le
tabouret et tu tapes de toutes tes
forces toutes mes forces
ici tout est faux mamma mia tu l'as ait
eu l'a pas eu
t'as pas aussi forts non mais c'est
juste le bruit gros jugé pas tout on
s'en sort pas ici note la buba
c'est incroyable le gros plan b moins
bien si vous perdez je ne lâcherai pas
le faire attendons de vous suivre et
jusqu'à chez vous au [ __ ] on est sûr
show coiffure chaud quoi oh les gars ce
jeu là la couronne début j'allais dire
qu'elle est vraiment ignoble dans cette
épreuve à chacun de tout remettre la
couronne et y aura des aliments qui
pendront de tout ça évidemment la
couronne tourne sur elle même le but
c'est de manger tous les aliments au
bout des fourchettes dans le temps
imparti qui commence c'est sofiane ça
tiens ça tient ok ok vas-y on ajoute les
aliments alors je dois faire quoi joue
l'elysée qui doit manger les aliments
épicés concours c'est qu'il ya un bien
car non pas celui qui fait qui m'est le
plus de temps howard
écoutez légation ps tous les deux à
écouter bon d'accord ils font ce cas là
sofiane oui tu as 30 secondes pour
manger le plus d'aliments top chrono
non je ne peux pas crocs mais ça va
tomber près je ne pouvais l'affiché ok
[Rires]
tu as perdu ta n'a pas eu un c'est à
dire que la loque temps attrape un et
arrête
d'après voici
accor non tu l'as pas bon ça compte pas
ça je suis désolé c'est pas rien si
désolé ça ne marche pas j arrive à
passer impossible voilà aucun warrick
blanche c'est la moitié d'un mois sur
l'autre ça le change à gaza n'est pas un
match mal d'amour et chouchoute les
fourchettes vu que tu à mâcher la moitié
des chamallows c'est très simple les
gars si j'en ai ne serait-ce qu'un vous
connais tous les deux une pile facebook
ou alors tu vois que ça paraisse jeu
lourd dans les travers d'un défaut à
travers la à quand la musique qui
finissent à dire c'est terminé depuis la
mer ce jeu suivant non non non mais non
les gars troisième et dernier jeu what
is what's in debout les gars ce jeu là
vous le connaissez il est extrêmement
simple
nous avons une boîte elle sera ouverte
les environs ce qu'il ya dans la boîte
il à lui maintenant c'est le soleil
bref on a chacun deux objets à deviner
logiquement qui commence c'est tout mais
[ __ ] allez vas-y mon mari sofiane
sofianh est ce que tu es prêt vas-y on
ouvre les portes comme ça la caméra voit
ce que c'est très bien très bien et top
ten minutes
la coût de sa mère
la [ __ ] je déteste ça je touche touche
là à l'aria je touche l'arrière
ok je loue la joue le l'emballage et la
bouffe et je sais pas j'ai envie
d'abandonner tu es bon tu le ferais
d'araser mes frères ok c'est un oignon 1
oignon y est ça l arrange bien vite le
dégager de la boîte parce que sinon elle
a fait un mort ouais moi des gars le
côté aliments ses vues et revues
j'ai pris bien d'autres choses ok j'aime
bien ça social donc ouais ouais ouais
locklear es tu prêt je sais pas à toi de
jouer
huawei pas tomber c'est un noix de coco
je n'ai plus envie de jouer c'est ça tu
as découvert c'est une noix de coco le
début de la vidéo était mieux je trouve
au [ __ ] les gars moi je suis nul à sa
rescousse
[Musique]
vous rigolez c'est quoi c'est très beau
c'est un truc de mozart un truc de
fromage c'est un truc que je peux mettre
mon doigt c'est un sextoy mettre mon
doigt dehors et à chartres à m noah
dedans y'a quoi là dedans je met un
doigt dedans
pourquoi oui je ne sais pas comment ça
je peux regarder mais man mais on sait
pas comment s'appelle en fait ce qui est
incroyable mais c'est un truc
oui ça c'est pas de stress association
puisque c'est très stressant mec sofiane
coincé à toi aller top chrono ou ça
valait alors sinon moi je la vis de ça
valait 5 secondes nul des null null null
null null il est nul d'ailleurs je vais
l'utiliser merci pour ce ballet une pire
bilan de ce jeu il a trouvé - luan croco
endroits du monde et je m'en bats les
autres deuxième objet à deviner pour
locklear c'est une prune nom un prénom
nom mais gros c'est dégueulasse tu
connais non mais c'est des grâces mais
qu'est ce c'est vicky de max est décrite
je vais la voir mais qui ne me dis pas
que ça rame en moins de firmin débat
citoyen
moi je sais pas ce que c'est je sais pas
vas-y regarde
ole conan conan c'est un vendu 5 0 mais
au bout il exprime au doublement sofiane
tu es un génie français incroyable et
bomba il me reste un objet à deviner
go/mois frère c'est un pot en plastique
à la fête de la fête foraine
c'est un jour plastique j'étais un jouet
en plastique doit deviner coincé une
glace au mal touche tout tu peux faire
quelque chose avec
c'est un joueur en place la fête foraine
baby shaq qui c'est qui va se prendre la
piste il a cependant été morte a juste
perdu mais qui tend à trouver car nantes
on en a trouvé deux chacun c'est
horrible je sais ça fait mal c'est le
principe de perdre sa foi sa fonction de
prêtre descoings soit l'autre coucou
c'est bon bon alors on fait quoi on met
une main chacun dans le truc est le
premier qui deviennent l'objectif dont
il a gagné une manche et une main chacun
dans le truc le premier qui devaient
loger la gagne et ça c'est bien sa
résille au teint hâlé
et je lui ai dit ma vengeance sera
terrible c'est beau c'est le moment de
la finale sofiane permettent un objet on
ne sait pas ce que c'est le premier qui
trouve à gagner l'autre il se prend
l'habit fait c'est prêt ouais 3 2 1 les
gones a archi breen honteux j'avais
prévenu s'était tu prends la presse
vous savez user de votre pouvoir non
c'est une honte ce que tu as fait j'ai
gagné j'ai gagné le truc atteindra
bientôt 30 ans claude as perdu tu as
triché
attention quand je chante rennes pour de
conscience taxe qui m'arrive deux
groupes
voilà que les remets ta tête et je n'ai
jamais vu de la mauvaise autant de
mauvaise foi dans cette vidéo de toi
aussi pour cela on s'en fout c'est la
chantilly
[Musique]
tu vois bien messieurs dames tout est
dégueulasse et pourtant cette vidéo
était propre éclater les gars j'ai adoré
ton cv vous j'adore faire des trucs
d'enfants et honnêtement je vous dirais
vérité ce jeu là pour moi il est extra
[Musique]
lol pas ça pour dire merci à vous
d'avoir regardé portez-vous
merveilleusement bien à ciao ciao ciao
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]